FOR THAT GREAT REPORT IN THAT
HOYA, TEXAS.
ERIC.
ERIC: THE PERSON WHO COULD HELP
DO THAT AND CALL IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT JOINS US NOW.
YOU SAW THOSE RUNNERS FLEEING ON
LIVE NATIONAL TELEVISION HERE ON
FOX NEWS, JUST A STARK AND
BRAINS EXAMPLE OF HOW OUT OF
CONTROL THE SOUTHERN BORDER
SEEMS TO BE.
THAT MAN LIVE IS TEXAS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL KEN PAXTON.
MR. PAXTON, MR. A.G., YOU’RE
SEEING THESE GUYS RUN.
DOES IT MAKE YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
WANT TO GET ON THE PHONE AND SAY
GO DOWN TO LA JOYA?
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY’RE RUNNING
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS DÉJÀ VU ALL OVER AGAIN.
IT CONTINUES TO HAPPEN.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
DOING WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO
STOP THIS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THEY’RE
INVITE ISING IT.
I’VE TALKED TO BORDER PATROL
MANY TIMES.
THEY ARE FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THEY
GET DIVERTED BY HAVING TO DEAL
WITH LOGISTICS AND HANDLING
THESE FAMILIES.
WE TRY TO HELP WITH TEXAS DPS,
WITH THE NATIONAL GUARD, BUT
THERE’S STILL NOT ENOUGH TO STOP
THE IMITATION THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ALLOWING TO
HAPPEN.
ERIC: HOW OUTMANNED ARE YOU?
>> IT’S SIGNIFICANT.
I FEEL BAD FOR THESE BORDER
AGENTS WHO ARE RISKING THEIR
LIVES, TRYING TO DO THEIR JOBS.
THEY’RE NOT ENCOURAGED TO DO
THEIR JOBS, NOT ENCOURAGED TO
PROTECT THE BORDER.
THEY’RE NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED.
THEY’RE NOT PUTTING UP THE WALL
WHICH BORDER PATROL WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE FOR THEIR OWN SAFETY,
LET ALONE THE SAFE THE -- SAFETY
OF THOSE ALONG THE BORDER.
IT’S INCREDIBLY FRUSTRATING WHEN
THEY’RE NOT GIVEN THE RESOURCES
NEEDED AND, AGAIN, THEY’RE
PUTTING THEIR LIVES AT RISK TO
HELP US.
ERIC: NEAR RECORD LEVELS IN MANY
YEARS, ALMOST 2 MILLION IN THE
LAST FISCAL YEAR.
HOW DO WE STOP?
YOU JUST MENTIONED THE WALL IN
YOUR STATE, TEXAS.
THEY ALLOCATED 250 MILLION TO
BUILD THEIR OWN WALL.
>> IT’S CLEAR TO ME THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT WANT TO
STOP THIS.
THEY HAVE CHANGED ALL THE
POLICIES THAT STOPPED THIS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IF HAD
IMPLEMENTED THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
PROGRAM.
THEY WOULD START DEPORTING
CRIMINALS WE HAD IN OUR JAILS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION STOPPED
ALL OF THAT.
WE’VE SUED THEM SEVEN TIMES.
WE’RE TRYING TO GET THAT
IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE WE’VE WON.
THEY’RE SUPPOSED TO BE
IMPLEMENTING THE STAY IN MEXICO
PROGRAM SO THESE PEOPLE DON’T
COME IN, CLAIM ASYLUM LIKE
THEY’RE DOING AND THEN DISAPPEAR
FOR YEARS AND WE NEVER FIND
THEM.
WE’RE DOING OUR BEST.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
FIGHTING US EVERY INCH OF THE
WAY, TRYING TO GET AS MANY
PEOPLE IN HERE ILLEGALLY WHETHER
THEY’RE CRIMINALS, WHETHER
THEY’RE TRANSPORTING DRUGS.
IT’S ALL GOOD WITH THEM.
ERIC: DO YOU THINK IT’S FAIR TO
SAY THAT IT’S GOOD THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
ENCOURAGING DRUG DEALERS AND
CRIMINALS TO COME IN?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT’S
HAPPENING.
THEY KNOW WHEN OUR BORDER AGENTS
ARE BUSY TAKING CARE OF HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE EVERY
MONTH, THEY KNOW THAT THESE
CARTELS ARE GAINING STRENGTH.
THEY CHARGE FOR ALMOST EVERYBODY
THAT CROSSES THE BORDER IS NOT
GETTING ACROSS WITHOUT PAYING
THE CARR TELLS I -- CARTELS AN
AVERAGE OF $8,000, THAT’S WHAT
I’VE HEARD FROM BORDER PATROL
AND FROM THE PEOPLE I’VE
INTERVIEWED THAT HAVE CROSSED
THE BORDER.
IT’S SIGNIFICANT MONEY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION KNOWS
THIS.
THEY’RE AIDING AND ABETTING THE
CARTELS IN NOT ONLY THE
TRANSPORTATION OF DRUGS, BUT
ALSO THE TRANSPORTATION OF HUMAN
BEINGS.
ERIC: THE ADMINISTRATION IS
EXPELLING LARGE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE, BUT WHAT DO YOU WANT TO
SEE THEM DO?
I MEAN, THE VICE PRESIDENT IS
THE BORDER CZAR.
WHAT SHOULD THE ADMINISTRATION
DO?
>> I WOULD ENCOURAGE THEM TO
FOLLOW FEDERAL LAW ARE, TO DO
WHAT THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO DO
UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
THESE LAWS HAVE BEEN PASSED BY
CONGRESS, SIGNED BY OTHER
PRESIDENTS, AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ON DAY ONE SAID
WE’RE NOT ENFORCING THESE LAWS.
IF THEY WOULD MERELY DO WHAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION DID WHICH
WAS ENFORCE FEDERAL LAW ARE, PUT
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO PROGRAM
BACK IN PLACE, DEPORT CRIMINALS
AND START BUILDING THIS WALL, WE
COULD HAVE AN IMMIGRATION POLICY
THAT WORKINGS.
AND THEN IF WE WANT TO ADDRESS
ADDING A GREATER NUMBER OF
PEOPLE TO COME HERE LEGALLY, I
HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT AS
LONG AS WE’RE FORCING OUR LAW --
ENFORCING OUR LAWS.
ERIC: FOLKS WATCHING US RIGHT NO
IN MAINE, JIM,OUT IN SOUTH
DAKOTA -- ILLINOIS, THEY HAVE
SAID THIS DOESN’T AFFECT ME.
BUT YOU’RE SAYING, WHAT ARE YOU
SEEING?
YOU GET IT FIRST IN TEXAS.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING AND HOW DOES
THAT AFFECT THE THE REST OF US.
>> WELL, CERTAINLY, THEY’RE NOT
GOING TO BE AFFECTED LIKE THE
PEOPLE ALONG THE BORDER WHOSE
PROPERTY IS DAMAGED, WHO ARE
SCARED TO GO OUT AT NIGHT
BECAUSE THEY DON’T KNOW WHO’S
CROSSING ILLEGALLY, CARTEL
MEMBERS, DRUG RUNNERS, THE
RUNNERS YOU ALL JUST SHOWED ON
IT’S ARE PROBABLY NOT PEOPLE
THEY WANT CROSSING THEIR
PROPERTY.
THEY HAVE NO CHOICE.
THIS IS GOING TO AFFECT THE
ENTIRE NATION BECAUSE THESE
PEOPLE ARE MOVED AROUND SECRETLY
OVERNIGHT ON PLANES AND BUSES.
SOME OF THEM HAVE COVID, SOME OF
THEM ARE DRUG RUNNERS.
THEY ARE POTENTIALLY CRIMINALS.
THEY COULD BE TERRORISTS, WE
DON’T KNOW.
WE JUST KNOW THEY’RE BEING MOVED
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY, AND WE
AREN’T ABLE TO KEEP TRACK OF
’EM.
ERIC: IT IS PRETTY ASTOUNDING
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE JUST SAW FOUR
OF THOSE RUNNERS LIVE WITH
APPARENT NO CONSEQUENCE WITH.
TEXAS ATTORNEY GENERAL KEN
PAXTON.